- Reindeers are real.
Christmas is real.
I swear to God if I can not
pass at least one challenge
this time, I just can't do anything right.
- I love Christmas, but I'm also an adult.
So I don't think I'll have
any trouble not smiling.
Also, my competition is Clark so --
- I will not smile because
I've been a bad boy.
(laughs)
- Things that would make me
smile paying my cell phone bill.
Paying my rent.
- Christmas sucks.
Let's go.
See the title is moving already.
I know I'm not gonna do good.
- Why are you smiling like that?
- I just like to smile.
Smiling's my favorite.
- This is actually my
favorite Christmas movie.
- Okay, people.
Tomorrow morning 10 a.m.
Santa's coming to town.
- Santa!
Oh my God!
(laughs)
I know him.
- This would make anybody smile though.
This is not fair.
- Boom, I did it.
I completed the first challenge.
This is my time.
- Got out all my little giggles.
I'm about to you know straight G-mode.
- [Man] You can't smile.
- Oh crap.
- Would you like to sit on Santa's lap?
- Okay.
Am I allowed?
- It's surprisingly
really hard not to smile
when you're looking at Santa Clause.
- How are you today?
- I'm good.
How are you?
- Mrs Clause had some,
some medical work done
so she can't really stand that well.
You can take my job.
- Santa (laughs).
(Santa mumbles)
- How about that?
This is the secret to marriage.
- Okay.
- Say yes and do what you want.
- How does that work out for you?
- She finally caught on.
So now Santa has a new routine,
and he says he's working on it.
- Okay.
- Would you like to sit on Santa's lap?
- Yeah sure.
- Okay, don't put all your weight down.
(laughs)
- Santa is an internet troll, an IRL.
- Santa is like really chatty.
- I smiled because it's just
like really awkward and creepy.
This is weird.
- This better not be no Buzz
Feed animals kicking bullshit.
- I don't know why we
sign up for this stuff.
- [Man] There might be like
an animal surprise there.
- I don't do animals.
I do humans.
- [Man] But then you lose the challenge.
- Okay, I'm thinking not happy thoughts.
I'm not gonna smile.
I am in a cage.
Oh my gosh.
Those are real live reindeer.
I didn't know that reindeer were real.
Do they have names?
A reindeer in Brooklyn.
What?
(laughs)
Did you just see its
half holly jolly shimmy?
Hi, Prancer.
(laughs)
They have majestic little shimmies.
Okay, I'm gonna say I've
failed this challenge
'cause I just want to like
revel in this beautiful moment.
(laughs)
It's a Christmas miracle.
It's the most wonderful time of the year.
Th spirit of Christmas
is alive in Brooklyn.
Happy Holidays.
Remember to smile.
Thank your parents.
(laughs)
And dance and prance and
jingle on your merry way.
Hi, you wanna dance with me?
Yeah, you want to do a little shimmy?